hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's edition of what I
eat in a day you'd per views is
sponsored by Squarespace and I'm gonna
be taking a look at Adrienne Bailon from
the YouTube channel all things Adrienne
now if you're not familiar with
Squarespace it is an all-in-one platform
to run your business whether you're
looking to build a website blog online
store or use their marketing tools and
analytics as a blogger myself I love
that Squarespace has a number of SEO
tools to really take the guesswork out
of making your site Google friendly and
it also has appointment scheduling tools
for online booking or coordinating
calendars I also obviously do a lot of
social media so bloggers will really
find the social sharing buttons helpful
while also setting up email campaigns
for mailing lists honestly when
everything in your digital presence
works together like this it makes it so
much easier for you to focus on your
actual business you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com slash Abby sharp to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain okay so now let's talk about
Adrienne so Adrienne is a singer actress
and co-host of the daytime talk show the
real and if you're a millennial like me
you may also recognize Adrienne from the
Cheetah Girls which is a bit of a blast
from the past to be honest most recently
however Adrienne has competed in the
masked singer so she's really talented
obviously and has a pretty impressive
and successful career and is now taking
on the YouTube world with over 1 million
subscribers I have received a lot of
requests from you guys to review
Adrienne's recent what I eat in a day
video and since it's the only what I
need a video on Adrienne's channel we'll
also be taking a look at some of her
other videos on her channel where she
talks about becoming a vegan and her
weight loss journey now of course before
we jump into my review I want to start
with my general disclaimer that the
information in this video is for
entertainment and
educational purposes only and you should
always seek out the help of a registered
dietitian or medical professional for
your unique healthcare needs also I want
to remind everybody to please be kind in
the comments No
shaming Adrienne no shaming me let's
just try to be respectful here finally a
quick trigger warning I am going to show
her weighing herself so if you are
sensitive to numbers you may just want
to fast forward ahead for like a minute
or so let's meet Adrienne so the first
thing I do when I wake up in the morning
is I brush my teeth I use the restroom
and then I would get on the scale and
weigh myself okay this is profile one
next to me I am a female
I am 411 I am 36 I 108 point six is my
weight and then it gives me everything
else okay
so in this clip which I didn't show the
whole clip but Adrienne mentions that
she weighs herself every morning using a
body analyzer aka the brand that
actually sponsored this particular video
and this is basically like a fancy scale
that measures certain anthropometrics
like weight water weight muscle mass
bone density and body fat I can
certainly understand why having this
type of device in your home and
receiving immediate like health
information about your body may seem
really appealing and handy to some
people especially those who may have
certain goals like fat or weight loss or
weight gain however I want to just
mention that the accuracy of body
analyzers has been questioned by the
medical community because there are
several variables that are just not
considered so body analyzers don't
consider where fat is stored in the body
so for instance body fat that is stored
around the organs in the abdominal area
aka visceral fat has more associated
health risks compared to the same amount
of fat that is stored in let's say the
lower body like the thighs in the bum
which is considered lower risk and
because women have a higher body fat
percentage a lot of that extra fat is
stored in the thighs and the breasts now
while I can understand that simply
stepping on a scale for this information
might be easier than taking a trip to
the doctor's office more accurate and
reliable body fat measurements would
include things like waist circumference
and skinfold measurements performed by a
trained health professional again just
an FYI
now Adrienne also mentions that she
weighs herself every single morning and
I can understand that if you have
certain weight loss goals you may be
weighing yourself more frequently to
kind of track that progress however I
will also flag that when yourself every
day can become an obsessive behavior and
may have detrimental impacts on your
mental health and self-esteem in some
people this is especially true for
individuals who may have a history of
body dysmorphia or eating sorters and
may therefore be a lot more susceptible
to engaging in unhealthy weight loss
behaviors due to that frequent and
obsessive weighing in fact one
literature review reviewing 20 different
articles found a negative relationship
between frequent weigh-ins and
psychological outcomes they found that
self-esteem body evaluation and eating
behaviors were all negatively impact by
engaging in regular self way it's also
really important to consider that weight
is constantly fluctuating as a result of
things like menstruation dehydration
caffeine and alcohol consumption your
last bowel movement what you ate etc so
if you weigh yourself every day or
multiple times a day you will likely see
pretty aggressive fluctuations in your
weight personally and professionally I
would not recommend weighing yourself
every single day especially if this is
triggering behavior for you I don't love
the scale in general but if you are
someone like Adrienne who wants to keep
track of their weight loss journey
progress weighing yourself about once a
week or just checking in with how your
clothes fit or how you feel would more
than suffice let's see what Adrienne has
for breakfast I don't know about you
guys you wake up too early in the
sometimes you're just not hungry listen
to your body pay attention to that this
will give me the energy that I need but
it's not heavy it is kale cucumber
celery parsley this has a lot of good
stuff in it you're not always gonna love
assess my thoughts on food and my
relationship with food because food is
not like pleasure yes you can have
pleasurable moments with food but that
shouldn't be the reason why you eat at
all times and it's actually for your
health benefits and keep you alive
okay so Adrienne starts her morning with
a nice big bottle of green juice and
that's about it I mean I don't know that
I would necessarily call this breakfast
however to be fair she is starting her
day off pretty early in the morning and
mentions that she's typically not very
hungry in the morning so I am glad that
she's kind of like listening to her
body's cues while still sneaking in a
little bit of fuel before filming her
talk show
however I will flag that a lot of juices
maybe not necessarily this one cuz it's
a lot of vegetables I don't see a lot of
fruit but a lot of them are typically
pretty high in sugar and low in fiber
which can leave you feeling hungry
shortly after especially if it's not
paired with another food that can
provide some of that fiber protein or
fat to help slowly release those sugars
into the bloodstream over time also like
I said this juice doesn't really qualify
as a whole breakfast meal to me because
it's seriously lacking in sufficient
calories so I am hoping to see a more
appropriate and balanced meal later on
in the day when she has a little bit
more of an appetite now Adrienne also
talks about eating for nourishment
versus eating for pleasure and while she
does have a point in saying that we we
eat to provide our bodies with a fuel
and nutrition that it needs to be strong
and healthy we also know that it's
healthy and normal to eat for reasons
beyond nutrients calories and numbers I
am Not sure that I agree with Adrienne
that seeing food solely as fuel is a
healthy mindset
especially if it means chugging down
food that you don't like just because
you think that you should having said
that a lot of people will probably ask
me at some point you know well is it
intuitive eating if you eat or drink
something preemptively even if you're
not hungry in the moment basically what
Adrienne is doing right now and to that
I would say yes it absolutely can be in
Adrienne's case having her green juice
when she's not really hungry before she
starts her show is an act of self-care
because she may be anticipating some
hunger or needing some fuel in the near
future maybe she knows that she'll feel
better with a little bit of fuel in the
tank when she has to go to work and that
if she had nothing she may get really
hungry at a time when she does not have
access to food like when you're on live
TV so this actually is compatible with
intuitive eating but I would like to see
her choose a food that is both
nourishing and enjoyable because these
categories are not mutually exclusive so
let's take a look at what she's having
for lunch and I hope that she enjoys it
now I am going to and I'm gonna put that
on a Quaker and I'm actually also going
to have this amazing vegetable soup
getting more roughage in your body or
drinking green juices is definitely
gonna make you use the bathroom that is
a good thing
cleanses your body and cleans your body
out you want your body to be as close to
a normal for a newborn baby as possible
they say that babies bodies are so clean
and pure when they're first born that is
why every time they eat something they
go to the bathroom right after okay so
lots to talk about here it's now
lunchtime which for Adrienne and her
crew happens around 9:00 in the morning
due to their early call time totally
makes sense Adrienne has a whole avocado
on two rice cakes along with some
vegetable soup now I am glad that we are
seeing some more substantial calories
here with this meal compared to just
like the green
juice this morning or in the morning
however for someone who is so concerned
with weight loss I am really missing the
protein here I mean we're getting lots
of great healthy fats from the avocado
not a whole lot of nutritional value
from the rice cakes to be honest but I
guess like some carbs and we're getting
some veggies in the soup I don't really
know what's in the soup exactly but one
thing to be aware of with a lot of
takeout soups is that they often contain
a lot of sodium which can make you feel
pretty bloated and even cause the number
on the scale to rise so just letting to
be aware of if you see an unexpected
spike because you're weighing yourself
every single day it's probably the salt
now Adrienne also makes some interesting
comments about regularity by claiming
that drinking green juice provides
roughage which helps you to go the
bathroom um not exactly
so roughage is a term used to describe
fiber which as we know helps to keep our
bowels moving and is really important
for a digestive health but the important
thing to note about juicing is that it
completely strips the fiber from the
fruit and the vegetables so what you're
really getting from juices is mostly
water content and lots of vitamins of
course but oftentimes a lot of sugar
especially if your juice has a lot of
fruit in it so most green juices do not
actually have much roughage in them at
all so feeling the need to go to the
bathroom after drinking a lot of green
juice is most likely attributed to
simply drinking more liquids from the
water content contained in that juice
which helps kind of move things along in
the bowels another reason for this
effect is that a lot of fruits and
veggies contain natural sugar alcohols
like sorbitol which can summarize have a
laxative effect in the body by pulling
water into the large intestine but
ideally you know we don't want loose
stools so what would probably do a much
better job at improving your bowel
movements would be to have a
with lots of fresh fiber rich greens and
veggies in their whole state plus some
water on the side now I also want to
note about Adrienne's suggestion that we
should be going to the bathroom as often
as newborn babies in order to cleanse
ourselves lose weight and achieve the
same purity as babies
uh no first of all babies go to the
bathroom more often not because they're
pure but because their digestive organs
like the stomach esophagus and
intestines are substantially smaller
than that of an adult a one week old
newborn stomach is about the size of an
apricot or plum so it can actually only
hold about 3 to 4 tablespoons of liquid
obviously then they have to feed like
every hour or so and they poop pretty
regularly newborn baby's guts are also
immature as they are actively building
digestive enzymes and healthy gut
bacteria hence why we don't give
newborns green juice or avocado we give
them breast milk or formula only so it
does not make sense to compare the
inputs and outputs of adult humans to
babies when these systems are
developmentally very very different I
also want to touch on Adrienne's
recommendation that we should be going
to the bathroom an hour after eating a
meal while drinking something like green
juice may or may not give you the runs
the time it takes for one meal to move
through your stomach and intestines can
take anywhere from one to three days or
more and this is necessary and important
in order for nutrients from food to be
efficiently digested and absorbed by the
body before excretion if you were to go
to the bathroom immediately after a meal
you may be bypassing critical steps in
digestion and absorption and missing out
on important nutrients from food and a
super speedy transit through the
digestive system is often the case with
things like diarrhea which is perhaps
the only time when you'll find yourself
running to the can in the hours
following a meal
where what is coming out is that meal
and I think we can all agree that this
is no fun for anybody
so a quick transit time through the
digestive system is not necessarily
ideal and would totally defeat the
purpose of eating that food or drinking
that really expensive green juice in the
first place because you wouldn't
actually be absorbing most valuable
nutrition that it provides and for what
I gather from Adrienne get in here
nutrients from green juice is definitely
a priority also contrary to what
Adrienne might be suggesting here
regularity is different for everyone
and is highly variable research shows
that normal bowel movement frequency can
be anywhere between three times per day
to three times per week depending on
diet hydration status exercise
preexisting gastrointestinal illness the
integrity of the gut microbiome
medication gender age stress etc it is
very unlikely that you're going to
completely change your daily bathroom
routine just by drinking some green
juice let's take a look at her snack I
went to briefing and I came back hungry
and it's in moments like this that I
have a few ideas of how you can curb a
craving I have a sweet craving right now
is what I'm craving I'm gonna try to
just chug an entire bottle of water
because that makes me feel full and then
I don't have my craving anymore don't
give it to the craving listen to me
watch this focus self-discipline I tell
myself self-love
he's self-disciplined
I'm going to chug this entire thing whoa
okay well where to start so for snack
time Adrienne is hungry not surprisingly
as she hasn't mean much today but
instead of giving in to her cravings she
has a big jug of water I can see why you
guys flagged this video for me to review
now Adrienne claims that this is kind of
her diet hacked to help her feel full
and encourages her fans to listen to her
and to not give in to their cravings and
instead just chug some calorie free
water her rationale is that the best
active self-love is self-discipline that
is so wrong the only appropriate self
loving response to your body's
legitimate need for food is food and
specifically food that is safe
culturally appropriate and enjoyable
this is a human right self-discipline at
the expense of meeting your body's needs
is the opposite of self-love like I'm
kind of mad that she even had to say
that now it's important that you know
that if you are hungry for a snack water
is just not going to fill that void in
fact this is a super old-school diet
myth that just has not held up in real
life if you've been told by diet culture
again and again that if you think you're
hungry you're probably actually thirsty
know that there is actually no strong
evidence to suggest that thirst and
hunger are actually confused these are
completely different sensations and
communication mechanisms in the body and
seriously folks when in your life were
you craving a piece of bread because you
were hungry and felt totally content
just drinking water instead never at
least not for very long so while water
may make you feel temporarily full from
the sheer volume it only perpetuates
feelings of guilt and
when you do eventually give in to your
craving for actual food which of course
may then trigger a binge let's hope we
have some real food for dinner in on
that as well
okay so it's dinner time and while
Adrienne's friends are enjoying some
pizza for dinner she opts for another
vegetable soup and a salad instead now I
can't actually really comment on the
salad as we don't know what it contains
or if she even necessarily ends up
ordering it as she just kind of mentions
it but restaurant salads can kind of
either go one way or the other right
they can either be really nutrient dense
and say shading and delicious and and
nourishing or they can be really sad and
boring but regardless of what Adrienne's
salad looked like overall this meal is
still incredibly low in calories and
protein and fat especially since she
also gave up you know that bread that
came off with her soup and given the
context of her day I was really hoping
to see a more substantial meal that was
far more balanced from what we've seen
in the rest of her day but sadly you
know that wasn't the case now to get a
better idea of Adrienne's overall diet I
looked at another video where she shares
what she generally eats on her vegan
diet for breakfast lunch dinner and for
a snack
it wasn't a full vlog style wedding day
like this one but at least she does give
us some insight into her weight loss
eating routine so let's take a look
breakfast fifty shades of green
oatmeal's I like to add blueberries to
my oatmeal it's a good antioxidant
avocado toast either on Ezekiel bread or
rice cakes protein shakes you guys can
make protein shakes for yourself in the
morning one of my favorite things ever
is to use true protein okay so we have a
little bit more to work with here when
it comes to her breakfast options so
oatmeal is of course a favorite of mine
as it's an excellent source of fiber and
complex carbohydrates to really start
the morning but of course I would love
to see some protein in there to help
balance it out so maybe some protein
powder or soy milk or powdered peanut
butter or hemp seeds on top not better
etc but definitely a much better option
than just the green juice that we saw
her drink all by itself
I would also much rather her go for the
Ezekiel bread over the rice cakes for
the avocado toast option as it is far
more nutrient dense and actually Ezekiel
bread has both 3 grams of fiber and 4
grams of protein compared to rice cakes
which have less than a gram of protein
and fiber each and then finally the
protein shake I mean depending on what
is in it would definitely be a lot more
satisfying and balanced than just the
green juice from day one but let's see
what she has to say about lunch I would
either like huge salads again with
avocado my favorite greens is arugula
peppers and literally just make myself
like this huge hearty salad ok so
there's definitely nothing wrong with a
nice big salad for lunch
I mean a hearty salad is immediately one
of my go-to lunch meals however it does
sound like her salads are mostly just
made up of large volumes of vegetables
and of course salads are an excellent
way to get in a ton of fiber and
vitamins but a girl can't live off
greens alone for a vegan salad to be
satiating enough for a meal we would
definitely want to see some plant-based
protein in there from some beans tofu
tempeh or edamame some healthy fats from
some olive oil or nuts or have a cod oh
like she mentioned which is great but I
would even throw in some complex
carbohydrates from foods like sweet
potato quinoa or some fruit in there I
mean when I think hearty salad I don't
just think vegetables and maybe
Adrienne's salads are beautifully
balanced and sage shading we don't
really know just from her description
but from what I've seen so far in her
vlog video I'm not really that
optimistic
now in another one of her videos where
she's disgusting eating more plant-based
she talks about how she eats out in
restaurants and that she always orders
either a salad or some steamed
vegetables from the side order menu now
I love ordering some extra veggies kind
of boost up the produce in my meal but
vegetables alone are not a meal in my
box and while I can totally understand
that transitioning to a vegan diet has
its challenges especially when going out
for dinner with friends
there are definitely so many vegan
options and alternatives now available
in restaurants but eating vegan
shouldn't mean exclusively only eating
vegetables let's see what she has to say
about snack I love nuts
I still love popcorn herbal green
popcorn organic vegan popcorn made with
spirulina created with love and my other
favorite snack
Asha Pops are amazing 100 calories for
this entire bag and it only has 17 carbs
dietary fiber is amazing guys ok am I
the only one who thinks that spirulina
popcorn kind of looks like weed but
anyways these are all great snack
options here definitely miles better
than the water chugging to mask hunger
that we witnessed earlier but nuts are
in my opinion a perfect snack because
they provide healthy fats protein and
fiber in one go popcorn is also one of
my favorite whole grains but ideally you
know we might want to see it turned into
like a trail mix with some seeds or some
nuts in there to help boost up the
satiety factor and I've never actually
heard of those Asha pop things but they
do have 4 grams of protein a gram of
fiber and 17 grams of carbs per bag not
bad but you probably would definitely
have to eat the whole bag to actually
get any adequate nutrition out of them
but anyway so she loves them looks good
to me
let's see dinner vegan chili I love
lentil soup roasted mushrooms sauteed
kale broccoli I felt so good about
myself because I was like I
I'm feeling myself with such good
nutritional food so again these are all
excellent vegan dinner options and I
also eminently obsessed with lentil soup
super easy to prepare and nutrient dense
and so budget-friendly but the beans in
the chili and the lentils in the lentil
soup would provide a good amount of
protein fiber and carbs so even though
we've probably picked up on the fact
that Adrienne does tend to like soups or
liquid meals I would much rather see her
have something more hearty and say
treating like vegan chili or lentil soup
versus straight-up broth or just
vegetable soup by itself so I am glad
and somewhat relieved that Adrienne
enjoys these types of vegan meals for
her dinners and I kind of just wish that
we saw this in her vlog style video too
so now let's get to some of my general
questions is this way of eating balanced
well because we are limited to only one
actual what I need a video on Adrienne's
channel plus some kind of general
suggestions on what she sometimes does
it's hard to even know if this is an
accurate representation of how Adrienne
regularly eats but just going off of
what we've seen Adrienne's diet left a
lot to be desired according to our
analysis Adrienne is consuming under 900
calories on this day meaning only 43
percent of her daily caloric needs 41%
of her daily carbohydrate needs 58
percent of her fat needs and about 33
percent of her daily protein needs so
she's basically missing out on half of
her body's needs for an entire day I
know that she's trying to actively lose
weight but this is a significant caloric
deficit not to mention that in one video
she discusses her exercise regime while
rehearsing for the masked singer and it
sounded pretty intense she talks about
doing 45 minutes on the elliptical twice
a day plus her dance rehearsal then
would perform four times per week and
lift weights three times per week whoa
that is
a lot especially on such little fuel I
would be very worried about the real
risk of injury extreme fatigue and loss
of muscle mass and strength which
ultimately would not support her in her
weight loss maintenance long term now
are there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel well I
want to start by discussing some of the
ways that she talks about her only lost
journey because there are definitely
some really important things that I want
to unpack let's take a look I want to be
healthy and I don't want to go on like a
diet I want this to be a lifestyle I
gave myself all of these goals and
deadlines that I had to make my goal was
getting to 105 pounds and I was willing
to do that in 3 months
ok so first I have to say that I think
it's really unusual that she claims that
she didn't want to diet and wanted it to
be a lifestyle which let's be real is
the enticing ruse of wellness culture
but if tricking your body into
suppressing hunger and sugar cravings
isn't a diet I don't know what is also I
can understand why setting specific time
base weight loss goals might seem really
helpful especially since diet culture
has led us to believe that you can lose
X amount of weight in X amount of time
however research has shown that it's
much more effective and beneficial in
the long term for your long-term health
to take the focus off weight loss as the
end goal and focus on day-to-day habits
and behaviors instead in other words
shifting your focus from outcome goals
to process goals by focusing on healthy
behaviors instead of achieving a
specific weight-loss goal or number it
may help us kind of adjust our thinking
and help us understand that our health
is based on so much more than just our
weight this means that we can start to
tune in to movement and ways of eating
that make us actually feel good and
continue to use those behaviors even if
they don't result in extreme weight loss
when eating more vegetables is strictly
tied to lose
wait we're kind of less likely to keep
it up when we do lose the ten pounds but
that is not how you build a healthy
lifestyle that is how you encourage
crash dieting that is just not
sustainable in the long term and it can
also encourage drastic unhealthy
behaviors to meet the short-sighted goal
let's see what else she has to say
I cut out major things from my diet
regular bread pasta I do not eat
anything that is white refined carbs
what do you want what do you want for
your life and if you don't want to give
up something then you don't want it
badly enough like there's no shortcuts
there's no easy way to do it you have to
make a decision within yourself to say I
am going to make a change so that I can
get the results that I want that makes
me feel good about me okay so Adrienne
here is talking about making sacrifices
like giving up foods that you truly love
in order to achieve your weight loss
goal I don't know I think this whole
insistence on extreme sacrifice is the
problematic concept in of itself I
strongly believe that weight loss does
not have to mean cutting out foods that
you genuinely enjoy and she clearly
loves bread she talks about loving bread
in fact by classifying a food that you
love as a forbidden or bad recent
suggests that we just kind of tend to
obsess over it and want it more often
resulting in a binge this is not the
sustainable lifestyle that Adrienne
talked about wanting for herself it is
also perfectly possible to include foods
that you actually love in your diet
while still having a weight loss school
and enjoying them in moderation honestly
the idea that not giving something that
means you don't want it badly enough is
so heavily ingrained in diet culture and
is riddled with victim blaming and guilt
and nobody needs that let's see what
else and I would drink a gallon of water
a day for me it was amazing I felt a
difference in my skin moments that I had
my crazy cravings I would drink hot
water with lemon and like that would
take the craving away or I would just
sit in like chug water
no I don't I just eaten you know when
you finish like a healthy meal and
you're like but I'm still hungry I've
been there drink water drink hot water
with lemon that is the key so I'm happy
to hear that Adrienne says she felt
great drinking a gallon of water I mean
if that's what your body needs
especially if you're running around
performing that might all means drink up
I mean listen to your body and pay
attention to those early signs of thirst
like dry mouth or concentrated urine but
she does talk about using the hot or
cold water to kind of kill her cravings
or help her feel full which as we've
already discussed is one of the most
long-standing pervasive diet culture
tricks I know now I want to make it
clear that drinking water is important
but there's also such a thing as
drinking too much water in that if it
gets excessive it can cause your sodium
levels to drop too low causing something
called hyponatremia which can be
dangerous and even fatal I'm not saying
that a gallon of water will necessarily
cause hyponatremia
I mean Adrian would know if it did but I
do want to caution that just because
water is good for you it doesn't mean
that it can't become not so good if
consumed beyond your body's actual needs
so the general recommendation is to
drink enough water to quench your thirst
while monitoring the color of your urine
to assess for overall hydration so
ideally we want your urine to range from
a light yellow like lemonade kind of
color to a light amber color like a
light beer you also don't want your
urine to be completely clear which would
be a sign that you might be drinking too
much water and you might need to pull it
back importantly if you're still hungry
after a meal like she suggests my
recommendation is to listen to your body
and choose fuel from food not try to
suppress your hunger temporarily by
stretching out your stomach with water
that is just a disrespect to your body
let's see what else she has to say I did
not eat out
from social events to your friends one
of the greatest tips I ever heard in my
life was from my trainer who got me
ready for my wedding she would see some
of my friends that would be around me
that literally would almost mock my
discipline and they would be like oh my
gosh just eat the bread Adrienne just
eat the bread she saw that happen and
she was like that's not your friend
anyone that is a distraction or someone
that's getting in the way of you
reaching your ultimate goal or doesn't
support you or encourage you you might
want to cut those people off okay so
what Adrienne is describing here is one
of the many reasons why dieting is so
hard for so many people for one food and
eating is a social phenomenon right we
often eat our meals around the dinner
table with our families or at social
gatherings at restaurants with friends
or coworkers we celebrate with food and
we mourn with food however what often
happens with dieting is that it can
inhibit these social activities either
because maybe the restaurant doesn't
meet our specific dietary restrictions
or an Adrienne's case because of the
perceived lack of support or food
shaming you get from friends I can
really empathize with Adrienne as it is
not nice for your friends to mock you
and not support your goals however I
think one question that I would want to
ask myself before I would go to the
extreme of cutting someone out is is my
diet or weight loss really worth losing
a friend so perhaps before making any
concrete decisions around phasing out
friend groups it might be helpful to
have an open conversation with your
friends or family and she mentions doing
this so let them know that this goal is
important to you and explain how they
can better support you so that you can
feel comfortable in social gatherings
that involve food also I would make sure
it's clear that you are not judging
their eating or pushing your diet agenda
on them as that is often a reason for
kind of the mocking or the pushback if
this is something that you're struggling
with I go into a lot more detail on diet
shaming in my video right here and in my
minds your own plate blog post that I'm
gonna be leaving in the description
below so let's see what else she has to
say self-discipline is sexy before
eating like the whole breadbasket I'd be
like damn self-discipline is sexy
because when you recognize how strong
your willpower is and how strong your
mind is you recognize that that ends up
being a common thread throughout every
area of your life again with the self
discipline which is basically another
word for willpower and while I do think
that discipline is an admirer will trait
for a variety of goals like work and
school Adrienne's definition of
self-discipline requires an enormous
amount of restriction which is very
likely to kind of set you up for failure
like I said earlier exercising
self-discipline by telling yourself that
you can't have something that your body
actually screaming for like food not
more water just makes you want it that
much more
and as our desire for forbidden foods
like bread builds you might actually
eventually cave and eat the whole bread
basket when maybe a single piece could
have easily satisfied your body's
desires and needs so it's very clear to
me that Adrienne has a fairly extreme
all-or-nothing approach to her diet
which obviously is working kind of well
for her now but statistically likely
won't in the long run again i 100%
believe that long-term weight loss is
possible and can be sustainable but any
lifestyle that requires you to
completely eliminate foods that you love
under eat by blunting hunger cues with
water and even cut out friends who don't
share your strict of diet is not what I
call a sustainable lifestyle the weight
loss may not be as drastic if you allow
yourself a piece of bread at dinner
but slow and steady wins the race here
or at the very least it doesn't make you
go mad I also want to touch on Adrian's
rationale for choosing a vegan diet now
apparently Adrienne was inspired by the
medical medium and decided to transition
to a vegan diet as a way to treat her
Hashimoto's disease now for those of you
who are unfamiliar with Hashimoto's
disease it's an autoimmune disorder that
affects the thyroid gland causing
hypothyroidism which results in a
decrease in the thyroid function and
hormone production however there is
actually very little research to support
consuming a vegan diet for Hashimoto's
disease or hypothyroidism we did find
one 2013 study which suggested that a
vegan diet may decrease the risk of
hypothyroidism however the results of
the study were not even statistically
significant one major concern that I
want to point out for individuals with
Hashimoto's disease or hypothyroidism
who may be following a vegan diet is the
importance of iodine iodine is an
essential nutrient necessary for thyroid
hormone production and individuals
following a strictly vegan diet may be
at higher risk of iodine deficiency due
to lower intakes of dairy and seafood
now some vegan friendly sources of
iodine that you definitely would want to
consider including in your diet include
seaweed iodized salt whole grain bread
prunes and lima beans again I'm not
saying that veganism causes iodine
deficiency I'm just saying that
statistically there is a slightly higher
risk I also want to mention that there
are some foods that may be beneficial
for some individuals with thyroid
dysfunction to limit so there are some
compounds called boi Trojans which may
have a negative effect on the thyroid by
interfering with some of the uptake of
iodine so some examples of goitrogens in
common foods include cruciferous
vegetables like broccoli bok choy
brussel sprouts and cabbage as well as
soy based foods like tofu tempeh edamame
and soy milk this is especially
important to consider in the context of
a vegan diet as it may rely heavily on
some of these types of foods you likely
don't have to
eliminate these foods but it is
something to be mindful that may be
problematic when consumed raw in the
case of the cruciferous vegetables or in
excess now the goitrogens and soy may
not be a huge issue for Adrienne but one
thing I am concerned about is her
caloric intake low caloric intakes have
been associated with decreased thyroid
hormones like t3 and t4 with research on
chronic starvation and restrictions
suggesting a very close relationship
between low food intake and abnormal
thyroid function so this is important to
consider if you're following a
particularly restrictive diet and are
susceptible to thyroid dysfunction we're
going to be talking a lot more about
Hashimoto's and hypothyroidism and
nutrition in a video that I'm working on
right now so definitely make sure that
you are subscribed so that you do not
miss out now all that said you know that
I think there are lots of reasons to eat
a vegan diet and I do not think that
hypothyroidism is a reason to
necessarily avoid it
so as long as eating plant-based makes
Adrienne feel better amazing this is
what I want to hear now overall I am
getting the impression that Adrienne has
sadly fallen into the deep end of a lot
of diet culture traps for instance we
see that she tends to fill up on a lot
of fluid rather than eating solid food
and any solid meal that she does have
tends to be very low in calories and
void of really important macro nutrients
like protein and carbohydrates we also
see a preoccupation with detoxing weight
loss avoiding sugar cravings drinking
lots of water and practicing
self-discipline to restrict calories
now while having a weight loss goal is a
personal choice that I totally support I
am concerned with the excessive level of
restriction that Adrienne is putting her
body through to achieve this goal
even though we only witnessed one full
day of eating if Adrienne is regularly
eating only 50% of her daily energy
needs while exercising at a pretty elite
level
I do have concerns about the long-term
impact of the severe restriction
metabolically reproductively and
psychologically listen I have a lot of
empathy for anyone working in Hollywood
who is not naturally a size-two it is an
unfair reality that a lot of really
talented people will have to fight extra
hard at the expense of their long-term
health just to fit in with the Hollywood
crowd judging by Adrian struggles with
her own naturally slim friends I can
only assume how difficult that must be
the bottom line is that some people even
in Hollywood are just not meant to be
waif thin our bodies have a certain
shape or size that they prefer to be and
I think Adrian is so incredibly talented
that if people do not see this despite
her size then they are the losers in
this the best diet is the one that is
sustainable in the long term and while
adrian states that she just wants us to
be a lifestyle
I wonder how realistic that is when
words like sacrificed and
self-discipline are consistently part of
her mantra ultimately folks my goal with
these what I in a day videos is to point
out some problematic content online to
help you make informed decisions and
help you build a positive relationship
with food it is not to tear people down
or criticize them so again please do not
attack Adrienne in this now while some
haze fans would probably disagree with
me I do believe that it is possible to
have a weight loss goal whether that's
for health or aesthetic purposes while
still eating in a balanced and
sustainable way but this was just not it
my hope is that Adrienne will find a
happy healthy medium as she continues on
her weight-loss journey and finds a way
to truly convert this into a lifestyle
that feels good
well folks that is all for today's video
a big thank you again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up
me a comment below with who you'd like
to see me review next until then
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]